[Musik]
auf der brust denn jetzt wo sind denn
die blauen haare ja ja das modell aber
ich hab' ich habe mir mit meiner mit sie
mich damit sie mich nicht für einen
youtuber halten habe ich heute auch
keinen blauen aber nicht das ist mir
ihre ihre krügerrand park mütze mit der
sie was in welchen sie könnten auf baby
elefanten chancen haben jahre jünger
seien zehn jahre wenn sie wissen sollten
und das ist hier außerdem müssen wir
schneller schneiden schneller als reden
damit genauso wie bei dem tollen video
von riese man nach zehn minuten
zuschauern zuschauen selber adhs hat
also selber irgendwie ein fest im sattel
sitzen sie drin liebe zuseherinnen und
zuseher da sehen sie wie der alte weise
man also er hier sich das internet
vorstellt man nimmt einfach eine mütze
dreht sie um und fängt dann an unsinn zu
reden und ich kann verstehen dass beim
blick auf das 10 millionen leute schauen
zu wie es großartig dass ein blick aufs
netz dieser eindruck manchmal entstehen
kann ich in diesem speziellen fall ist
es allerdings nicht so in diesem fall
ist es so dass ein youtuber der sonst
irgendwas macht keine ahnung ich kannte
den vorher gar nicht bin ich auch ein
alter wassermann etwas gesagt hat was
leute wie ich ehrlich gesagt dieser zehn
jahren schreiben nämlich dass das mir
kommen am wandel nicht so darum ist es
richtig weil sie seit zehn jahren
schreiben interessanter ist das
interessante ist plagen das ist
interessantes noch was anderes das
interessant also worum geht es ja wieso
video mann mit blauer tonne vor der wahl
60 minuten video zerstörung der cdu über
den titel kommen wir nochmal reden
erneuerbare energien nicht gefördert zu
wenig klimawandel zu wenig dagegen getan
bildungschancen zu wenig getan aber hat
also zwei mal aufgelistet was in diesem
land nicht so gut funktioniert hat dann
gesagt die cdu regiert das land seit dem
jahr 1235 und so dazwischen besteht ein
zusammenhang und deshalb cdu logo so das
hat ja so gemacht ok und dann fallen
alle leute also alle leute so wie sie
über ihn gesagt um gottes willen das
kann er doch nicht machen und so und da
muss ich sage jetzt mal mit herrlichen
gehören das hat das echt nicht was das
war ganz schön ihr habt das internet
nicht verstanden und die
meinungsfreiheit und was heute
journalismus ist echt aber haben aber
ganz fest
dass der so scharf kritisiert worden sei
ich hatte eher das gefühl die halbe
republik hat sich vor glück flachgelegt
auf den rücken das endlich mal jemand
kommt und die republik beschreibt wie
sie ist und endlich mal wahlkampf macht
für achtung natürlich nicht unbedingt
die großen parteien also die vormals
großen parteien spd
da hat er auch gesagt bitte nicht whf
degut geschenkt aber auch gesagt bitte
nicht wählen er hat nicht gesagt wen er
wählen würde ist blieb dann aber auch
nicht mehr so viel übrig also man konnte
ahnen wohin der hase läuft in diesem
fall des internet nämlich zugunsten der
grünen fällen auf es gab auch schon
marianne rosenberg und marius müller
westernhagen die haben der dampf
betrieben damals zur wahl von gerhard
schröder aufrufen oder veröffentliche
anderen kanzler meinetwegen auch angela
merkel stimmung gemacht ist alles
vollkommen okay du hast nicht so richtig
okay es ist so die der der 100% focus in
unserer wahnsinns welt tschuldigung auch
medialen wahnsinns fällt alles schaut
nur noch auf wieso haben wir richtig
reagiert haben wir falsch reagiert aber
hat er die wahl entschieden war und nein
er hat die warum nicht warum warum warum
haben sich die leute denn überhaupt mit
dem thema beschäftigt warum beschäftigen
wir uns jetzt damit sagen sie nochmal
den grund warum ist es wird ein thema
weil der grund ist streit sich zu
stellen ist nein das wie viele klicks
der typ hatte und dass der erst
interessant dann hat eine audienz über
ist ob die jetzt also das zu ende
geschaut haben weiß der geier aber ist
ja auch egal ist eine ganz ganz große
hammer über 12 millionen soweit ich weiß
momentan werde die zahl die ich
mitbekommen habe die zahlen steigen dann
ja auch immer weiter haben sich das
angeguckt in einem umfeld wo
normalerweise leute sich gegenseitig
dabei filmen wie sie rührei machen dazu
dann irgendwie wahnsinnig witzige
kosmetik tipps geben und das wird alles
noch finanziert von der industrie und
dann sagt man immer irgendwie die sind
alle gekauften und das doch das
interessante das ja auch für mich
interessant
ich meine ich bin ja im grunde berufs
melancholiker und ermahnung es geht
sowieso alles vor die binsen in diesem
speziellen fall muss ich sagen
hoffnung keimt auf weil wenn in dem
umfeld viele leute in der lage sind sich
mit komplexen politischen themen 60
minuten ist echt ne lange für eine
verdammt lange zeit
da steckt eine menge arbeit drin in dem
teil das haben sie aber wirklich sagen
es ist halt nur die glaubwürdigkeit der
absender quellen haben sie hatten ganz
offensichtlich nicht gesehen sie wissen
dass er dass er das statistische
bundesamt die bundesregierung
der spiegel zeit welt an darunter die
quellen die er zitiert hat mein lieber
freund sind unsere quellen und das doch
das lustige daran und ich finde es eine
lustige geschichte wie ich meine
die neue geliebte parteivorsitzende der
cdu hat sofort praktisch gleich gesagt
so ja also wir sind vor den wahlen dann
leute einfach im internet dinge sagen
die sie wollen und das ist ohne
regulation darüber müssen wir mal
nachdenken und das hat sie gesagt zehn
tage nach herrn strache und er ist
überhaupt nicht aufgefallen was das für
eine han sol ist mein hauptziel sind
darunter
bei strache strache will die kronen
zeitung kaufen und manipulieren dass
damit sorgt das gesagt hat
der internet-anbieter auch den medien
berichten was er will und unsere
bundeskanzlerin
halo ist ihnen aufgefallen denn erst
wenn es bestimmt nicht diesen oder im
internet trat beim ärgste selber ja ja
da merkst dass du willst finde die ihre
nie finden sie den fehler
ich werde jetzt nicht frau kramp
karrenbauer verteidigen wie sich echten
schnee gelegt hat komplett als sagte wir
müssen mal über regeln für diese art
inter und wenn sie sagte dass für sie
verglich ist ja mit 70 chefredakteuren
die sich dann wenn die sich denn so
verschwören würden dann vermutlich um
einen wahlaufruf zu machen klammer auf
das müsste sie auch ertragen
selbst wenn es dazu käme dazu wird es
aber nicht kommen bei chefredakteure
zeitungen vorstellen und zeitungen
machen keine wahlaufrufe zumindest das
gelernt in deutschland aber es macht die
fifa nennt ihr tage sein macht aber
sonst wenn sie es machen wollten könnten
sie sagte ich mal jede zweite kann
natürlich wahlaufruf wahlprogramm
karlsruher müsste das ertrage
selbstverständlich ja oder machen sie
das muss dann sozusagen kennt dann ich
glaube doch die globalisierung der
niederlande aber in der zeit und das tun
macht sich was kaputt nämlich ein stück
glaubwürdigkeit beim weiteren berichten
über die regierung ließ da sie rosen ist
jetzt hat auch nicht ihre zu entscheiden
erst das nennt sich dann freiheit sie
erinnern sich herr freiheit nun schon
drei mal gesagt sie müsse es ertragen
wenn es dazu käme ich glaube es nur wäre
nicht klug aus sicht der zeitung dass zu
machen punkt in der durchsage
wieso kann im netz machen was er will
außer er überschreitet irgendwelche
strafrechtlichen grenzen was er
eindeutig nicht hat mir geht es um die
frage warum hat das so ein ehren anklang
weil es so radikales weil es so und ist
doch gern mal halt auch einseitig ist
tatsächlich gelesen und weil es auch
einseitig ist weil es in einem irren
tempo geschnitten ist also moderne ist
wenn sie so wollen also die gar nicht
mehr mit dem gucken die inter jetzt noch
nicht und jetzt dieser hass ist aber
alles viel zu viel es geht aber
überhaupt nicht mehr und früher drittes
programm
sie sind doch eine nummer merken sie das
gar nicht wir beide sind doch nein nein
sie massiv sie knien nieder vor dem stil
von rechts vor dem tempo vor dem dings
ich kann überhaupt nicht natürlich geht
er auf die machten hinten hier gleich
eine blaue karte anfangen wieso und
womit und ich hätte noch ein zwei fragen
und vor allen dingen das ziel der
veranstaltung die tonalität der
ansprache die maximal das maximale
dringliche des anliegens wir müssen das
jetzt machen denn in dem video in dem
ersten video war ja auch davon die rede
wer das jetzt hier nicht glaubt wer hier
jetzt nicht 100 prozent mit geht der hat
keine legitime meinung mehr dessen
meinung ist nicht mehr legitim
und da fängt schon irgendwie aus zu
harken findet das ist sehr
unterschiedlich und die gegend rennt ist
bei der bildzeitung also wer geht da
denke ich an so themen so migration zum
beispiel wurde auch die haben wir dann
nach ost konflikt übrigens das hier ist
also die sozusagen die die haltung
wer hier abweicht von sozusagen begibt
sich außerhalb davon ich glaube
erhaltung ist ihnen bei der bildzeitung
vollkommen fremd also niemand populismus
das ganze gar nein das ist nicht
populismus zumindest nicht gleichermaßen
und immer gleichzusetzen ich finde
israel ist kein gutes beispiel aus
deutscher sicht dass in diesen topf mit
rain zu hören wenn ich das noch mal
anmerken darf man ich meinte nur nehmen
ihre strenger linien sozusagen
wir haben gleich an dass jemand ihn hier
würden nicht schreiben wer findet dass
der mindestlohn eine gute sache ist oder
wer findet dass der mindestlohn eine
schlechte sache ist vertritt jeweils
eine illegitime meinung wir würden zum
beispiel auch nicht sagen wer also aus
dem kanon des vertretbaren schießen sie
sich raus wenn sie sagen die erde
erwärmt sich nicht ja da recht da haben
sie recht habe ich auch rechte das sage
ich auch wenn sie schießen sich aus dem
kanon der vertretbaren meinung heraus
wenn sie sagen das hat nichts mit den
menschen zu tun bin ich auch dabei
dahinter aber wir regeln wir es denn wir
hätten wir es denn gerne wie machen wir
es denn da wird eine totale
gewissheit vorgegaukelt die offenkundig
ankommt 12 millionen nach links alle
total nett und eine inbrunst vortrags
moment die nicht geht in einem
politischen diskurs nachdem der mann
seine komik lach mich tot dass der
kollege von der bildzeitung sagt die
inbrunst des vortrages geht nicht wenn
sozusagen sie immer abschiede rankings
machen so wer schiebt am meisten abwehr
gibt zu wenig ab hier muss noch viel
mehr abgeschoben werden und da wissen
sie auch ganz genau was richtig ist dass
der kollege mit henrys oder gemacht hat
ja in dem fall nenne ich ihnen jetzt mal
kollegen war für einen kurzen moment
seines lebens ich weiß nicht was vorher
war ich weiß auch nicht was noch kommt
aber für einen kurzen moment seines
lebens war der mann journalist deshalb
das interessante daran ein er war ja ein
journalistischer aktivist und das ist ja
sagen dann sage ich völlig ohne
abwertung er ist ein aktives es kann
dann wäre man dann alles marianne
rosenberg für herrn schröder geworben
hatten das genommen hat ist eine kleine
das ist interessant abstand es ist nicht
wahr er hat nicht geworden er hat sich
nicht hingestellt und gesagt warum
wählen sie spd oder wählen sie cdu oder
wählen sie die grünen was er gemacht hat
dass er hat themen
er hat 60 minuten lang themen durch
gelernt sie haben es offenbar nicht
gesehen und sie haben es an sich entlang
des ersten videos kommt ja wirklich spd
wirklich cdu wirklich afc und was bleibt
dann noch ganz genau
die fdp die fdp also viele viele
menschen sich keine werbung gemacht wenn
sie das auch für den menschen beim baden
ddp
wir sind diesmal hat er hat themen
verhandelt er hat doch er hat doch die
ganze dass die ganze zeit sich mit
themen beschäftigt und warum sie so
durchdrehen warum auch waz altenbockum
praktisch die krise gekriegt hat warum
die cdu die krise kriegt hat ist dass
sie plötzlich das gefühl haben da kommen
junge leute die mit den mitteln des
internets und mit den mitteln der
polarisierenden zuspitzungen einfach die
themen wegnehmen und sagen einfach sagen
und ich meine entscheidung ich muss ich
muss doch gar nicht mehr da wir ein
gatekeeper monopol und eindeutiger
darstellung das monopol als medien
klassische medien verloren haben ist
doch logisch
das ist doch nichts neues ist zeigt uns
doch nicht wieso jetzt als erster hallo
ich erst kommen sie mit dem erfolg nicht
zu rechnen
aber das sagen wenn du hundert tausend
leute sich
das angeguckt hätten würden sich jetzt
hier nicht stehen dadurch dass sich das
zwölf millionen leute angeguckt haben
denken alle ich heiße ist was falsch
gelaufen und ehrlich gesagt ich lass
mich doch tod den ganzen quatsch
der typ der sagt schreibe ich seit zehn
jahren sage ich dass das ein ungerechtes
land ist dass die soziale schere
auseinander geht dass die steuerpolitik
für die reichen gemacht hat bla bla bla
bla bla
die cdu ist verantwortlich die spd ist
der steigbügelhalter des neoliberalismus
das ist mein text der mann hat die ganze
zeit in meinem text geredet in wahrheit
nur neidisch kann natürlich und ich
freue ich freue mich dass es so wird und
andererseits bin ich so ein bisschen
neidisch weil ich denke mit diesem video
hat der mehr leser und mehr wirken
erzählt als ich mit meiner ganzen arbeit
wirkung hat er dann erzählt da stimmt
doch gar nicht das ist ja das was ich
bezweifle dass er wirken als die jetzt
heißt er hätte die wahl entschieden
ach ja so weit in die kurorte in die er
gesendet hat die sich das angeschaut hat
möglicherweise auch zweimal angeschaut
haben als jetzt nämlich lang war die ist
doch nicht wahlentscheidend weiß ein
bisschen sie doch das wissen wieder in
der altersverteilung das spannende ist
doch dass die grünen jetzt endlich auch
mal darauf zu kommen dass die grünen
längst in andere alterskohorten
eingegriffen haben also hinein senden
mit hilfe meiner wegen der brand
beschleunigt von riese und darum so gut
abgeschnitten haben aber ob die 18 bis
25 jährigen jetzt das gesehen habe und
sich beeinflussen lassen ist für eine
wahlentscheidung beziehungsweise einen
wahlausgang vor allem vor allen dingen
war leider so wenige swype kam erst nach
der wahl fun fact fun fact ja auch im
jugend deutsch gesagt fand weg zum
schluss die csu hat kundgetan möchte ich
mal sagen den bayernkurier auf papier
einzustellen ja man kann sich das nicht
mehr leisten der bayernkurier wird
eingestellt sehr sehr schade war eine
meiner lieblingszeitung natürlich und
digital wollen sie jetzt irgendwas
machen aber erstmal braucht man noch
digitale gehhilfen so hat die das
ausgedruckte csu das will ich auch keine
gehhilfe eigentlich doch alles lauert
rückhalt habe der csu ist achtung das
internet ist ebenso lang neuland wie so
leute wie der csu geschickt
[Musik]